in 2017 masayoshi son convinced someone
to invest 45 billion dollars into his
SoftBank Vision fund and he did it in
just 45 minutes
was this mysterious investor what can
his eagerness to invest tell us about
the vision fund and what did Masa say to
convince him to invest so much money
today the insane story of the rise and
fall and rise and fall of masasone
SoftBank and the vision fund there are
two kinds of people when you make
mistakes one kind of people don't want
to admit that you have made us mistake
and those people try to make all kinds
of excuses and the other group accept
the mistake I would rather accept my
stupidity my ignorance so that
Master Yoshi's son was born on the 11th
of August 1957 in a city in the
southeast of Japan called tosu if you
think son is an unusual Japanese family
name you're right Masa is a third
generation Za anichi Korean the name
given to people of Korean descent whose
families came to Japan during the
colonial period xanichi Koreans are the
second largest ethnic minority in Japan
but many like the sewn family were
discriminated against Masa grew up in
the kind of poverty that is totally
unrecognizable from his wealth today his
childhood home was a shack illegally
built on land that was owned by Japan
National Railways he shared it with six
siblings masa's father scraped together
a living for the family by raising pigs
and chickens on this tiny parcel of land
eventually he started an illegal sake
business the business was successful and
the family was able to buy a car and
move to a new neighborhood closer to
better schools masa's energy and
eagerness to learn were obvious from a
young age his business career year began
after he met his Idol Den Fujita now Den
Fujita was a fascinating guy in his own
right his main claim to fame was
bringing McDonald's to Japan after first
eating one of their burgers in 1967 then
became obsessed he believed that if
Japanese people eat McDonald's
hamburgers and potatoes for thousands of
years we will become taller our skin
will become white and our hair blonde
kind of crazy to say that he overcame
deep skepticism that McDonald's would
ever succeed in a country like Japan and
built a network of thousands of
restaurants Masa was captivated by Den's
ambition and his ability to bridge
Japanese culture and Western culture Den
urged Masa to study English and learn
about the rapidly emerging computer
industry and to do so in America Masa
had a burning desire to overcome
adversity and Elevate his family name to
the position he believed it deserved
later when he was an established
entrepreneur masa's colleagues would
cite his Outsider complex as a key to
understanding his approach to investing
more on that later at the the age of 16
Masa decided he wanted to move to
California and he told his family he was
going by himself his mother was
heartbroken how come you're leaving us
and going all the way to the United
States she asked in disbelief it's a
bunch of Barbarians who live in that
country masa's father was more
circumspect he knew his son had a strong
will and that he was stubborn this was
his decision no one was going to change
his mind so he knew the best thing he
could do was to provide him with some
money Masa flew to Oakland there was a
Catholic University there called holy
names College which had a special
program for foreign students to learn
English because he'd already spent three
months as a freshman in Japan Masa
entered high school as a sophomore after
one week he was promoted to a junior
after another week he became a senior
after half a week of being a senior he
took an exam and graduated Masa son
graduated from an American High School
in a language he had been learning for
only a few months in two weeks he
returned to Holy names college for his
freshman and sophomore years they were
actual years this time before
transferring to Berkeley to study
economics but he didn't forget the
advice of his Idol Den Fujita so he made
sure to also take some computer science
courses for many people college is a
time to learn about yourself and meet
other people but for Masa College was an
opportunity to try out the hundreds of
different business ideas his Relentless
mind had come up with inspired partly by
den and partly by his own reading Sone
became convinced that computer
technology would Define the next
Commercial Revolution and that it would
yield him his fortune Masa decided he
would generate one entrepreneurial idea
a day he wrote them down soon he had
more than 250 ideas one of those ideas
would wind up making Masa his first
million
but he needed some experts to create a
prototype Masa chose the simplest way to
achieve his goal he looked through the
faculty directory found the names and
details of some microcomputing staff and
convinced some of them to form a project
team with him you should already be
getting a sense of how good he is at
convincing other people to do stuff for
him he told them he didn't have any
money he was 19 but that they shouldn't
worry after Masa got the money for his
patent he would pay them and that's
exactly how it panned out Masa sold a
patent to Sharp Electronics for a
translating device then Masa did with a
lot of suddenly Rich 19 year olds would
have done in the late 1970s he imported
a bunch of Space Invaders video arcade
machines he rewrote the software on the
machines and installed them across the
Berkeley campus in restaurants dorms and
cafeterias that idea made him another
million dollars before he graduated Masa
started a game software company called
Unison World which he would eventually
sell for almost 2 million dollars but
first Masa did something unexpected he
moved back to Japan to start another
company for a year and a half he just
did research and made business plans he
lived off the income he had made in
America but eventually masa's family
grew concerned it didn't look like he
was doing anything he was just reading
and writing things down but like an
iceberg most of the action was going on
underneath the surface Masa developed
more than 20 measures of success to
guide his thinking his most important
one was that he should fall in love with
his business for at least 50 years that
way he would stick with it even when
times were tough he took a big sheet of
paper and Drew a matrix with all of his
ideas and scores and comments for each
then he picked the best one the personal
computer software business satisfied
with his choice Masa called his new
company SoftBank I think founding and
building SoftBank in Japan rather than
America is one of the most fascinating
decisions Masa son made in his entire
career think about it he had made
millions of dollars in America sure
Japan was home but it had lots of
unhappy memories Masa was determined to
go against conventional wisdom and he
had unshakable self-belief he believed
SoftBank was destined to become a global
success therefore he believed it should
be based in Japan why because even
though it would be harder to get the
business off the ground being based in
Japan would make it easier to win the
Loyalty of his employees Japanese
workers Masa claimed put in longer hours
and stayed with their employers for
decades but they lacked in originality
and made up for in commitment to
continuous Improvement Masa compared
this slightly stereotyped view to
American workers who he believed were
more likely to jump ship to the next
opportunity in a heartbeat it's almost
impossible to imagine someone making
that decision or using that reasoning
today founders-based software companies
in America for two reasons access to
Capital and access to Talent when Masa
made his decision more than 40 years ago
the software industry was Tiny compared
to today but he was also reasoning on
totally different principles by 1981
Masa had two part-time employees and a
small office one day he brought in a
couple of boxes and stood on them to
give a speech to his team you guys have
to listen to me he said because I'm the
president of this company in five years
I'll have 75 million dollars in sales
I'll be supplying a thousand dealer
Outlets will be number one in PC
software distribution according to Masa
these two guys both quit on the spot a
year and a half later SoftBank was
supplying 200 dealer Outlets Ten Years
Later it was supplying fifteen thousand
how well like so much of masa's Career
Success was forged from failure when
SoftBank was just a couple of months old
he reserved a booth at a consumer
electronic show in Tokyo he made sure
that it was as big as the booths that
big name companies like Sony and Toshiba
had Masa called all the software vendors
he knew he told them that he was going
to pay for all the collateral and that
they could set up in his booth for free
it was a big idea and a big failure no
sales no leads nothing were so Moss of
thought a few weeks after the show he
received a call from Osaka the guy on
the phone said he was starting a big PC
shop and that he needed software and he
asked Masa to come to Osaka for a
meeting Masa said no was this yet
another example of him defying
conventional wisdom not exactly Masa
just didn't have the money the guy
wasn't deterred do you know my company
he asked Masa it's called joshin denki
Masa said he didn't but he figured that
he should ask around so he called up
sharp he still knew some guys high up
there from when he sold them his patent
while still a Berkeley student their
reaction was unanimous they immediately
told Masa to go to Osaka when the
representative from Joe Shin denke
called back he threw Masa a life jacket
oh our president is actually coming to
Tokyo for some other business you could
meet him Masa met with the president of
Joe Shin denki the company already had
some software and a direct Channel with
some vendors but it needed more masa
said if you want to do business with me
you'll have to break off those
relationships if you want to succeed
with PCS in Japan it's my way or the
highway this was kind of crazy we just
heard that Masa didn't even have the
money to travel to Osaka to meet with
this guy this is his only solid lead and
he's setting the terms Masa continued
his pitch I have very little money he
said and very little business experience
I have no product okay so what did he
have the greatest desire to succeed Masa
freely admitted that the president of
joshin denki probably had more knowledge
and more experience than Masa did but he
said I will dedicate all my time and
effort all my energy my entire Spirit
exclusively to PC software if I do that
who do you think will be more of a
specialist a few months from now if you
want to be the number one PC dealer in
Japan you have to find the number one
guy in software distribution that's me I
have no evidence but I strongly believe
in myself I'll admit it I think this is
a genius pitch Masa didn't want to take
his knowledge his experience or his list
of clients so he opted for the approach
that was already becoming his signature
style faith in himself and infinite
optimism about the future it worked the
president gave Masa exclusive purchasing
rights for all of Josh and denki's PC
software if you thought you recognized
masa's pitch that got his foot in the
door with Josh and denki then you'll
definitely recognize his follow-up
because it's the first real example we
have of masa's son applying the thinking
that would come to sum up his approach
to investing Masa said to the president
I will get you every software product I
have the contacts what I don't have is
the money if you want all the software
you'll have to pay for it and you should
having all the software is critical some
of it won't sell but you'll make up the
loss because word will spread that you
have the biggest range when he said this
Masa was looking into the future he had
total belief that Computing technology
would become widely used which meant
that overall investing in software made
sense even if some of the products
flopped as an overall asset class it was
a great investment remember Masa became
convinced that software was the future
while at Berkeley he may not have had
all the evidence on hand but he had the
most important thing belief Masa went
around to department stores and
electronic stores he'd ask Executives if
they'd heard of joseon denke and if they
knew why the company was the biggest PC
dealer in Japan the answer according to
Masa was that they used SoftBank for
their software procurement needs within
a year softbank's monthly revenues went
from ten thousand dollars to 2.3 million
dollars and they just kept going up from
there SoftBank went public in 1994 at a
valuation of three billion dollars Masa
son was a rich man he could have cashed
out and not worked another day in his
life but his ambition burned too bright
and his belief in himself and the future
was too strong so he did the most Masa
thing possible he went back to America
this time to conquer it let's pick our
story back up in 1995. at this point off
Bank was 15 years old and worth billions
of dollars Masa son had become a
self-made man so why did he move to
Silicon Valley a place with dense
networks that were hard to crack for an
unconnected Outsider because Masa saw
the future he saw how brightly it
gleaned and he believed he was the
person who would capture it the future
he saw was built on top of the first
wave of the.com bubble today we remember
the bubble because of how spectacularly
it popped but we forget the revolution
too easily the.com bubble inflated for
two reasons one was the increasing
popularity of the internet the release
of early browsers like Mosaic coupled
with the emergence of Windows as the
default home operating system meant that
more and more people were surfing the
web between 1990 and 1997 the share of
American households with computers
increased from 15 to 35 percent computer
ownership went from a luxury to a
necessity and lots of companies were
poised to take advantage one of them was
Yahoo masasone knew all of this because
in 1994 SoftBank bought the trade show
division of a company called zif Davis
the leading organizer of computer
conferences in the United States He
described the acquisition as a way to
get a map and a compass for a voyage
into the center of the booming
technology industry in early 1996 with
his map Encompass in hand he strode into
Yahoo's new office in Mountain View and
proceeded to casually take the Silicon
Valley arms race to a whole new level
with a 100 million dollar bid for a 30
slice of Yahoo it was unprecedented at
the time Top Flight Venture Partnerships
usually raised around 250 million
dollars there was just no way any one
investor would put 40 percent of their
resources into a single 100 million
dollar wager but Masa wasn't playing by
anyone else's rules after sitting in
silence for a while Jerry Yang one of
the co-founders said he was flattered
but he didn't need the capital Jerry
Masa quickly replied everyone needs a
hundred million dollars he was right
Yahoo needed to build its business and
put its product in front of more
consumers the normal path for a young
company looking to raise millions of
dollars was to go public but here came
Masa casually offering the kind of
investment that usually required an IPO
with none of the complicated public
ownership he was ready to shake hands
then and there Yahoo's Founders and Mike
Moritz of Sequoia Capital needed some
time to respond masa's offer was
tempting but Yahoo was already working
with Goldman Sachs on an IPO and if
Goldman Sachs made good on their
prediction a public listing would value
the company twice as highly as masa's
offer and make them all a lot richer
Masa sensed that the deal was on the
verge of slipping out of his grasp so he
upped the stakes so he asked the men on
the other side of the table from him
what Yahoo's main competition was excite
they said and lycos Masa was quiet for a
moment then he said to the founders if I
don't invest in Yahoo I'll invest in
excite and I'll kill you it was a threat
and it showed that Masa understood
something import important about
internet-enabled startups in most
Industries there would be only one
winner so the investor who could write a
100 million dollar check could choose
who won the race just like The Godfather
Masa made Yahoo's Founders an offer they
couldn't refuse
they decided to take masa's money but to
also proceed with an IPO Yahoo went
public in April of 1996. its share price
closed at two and a half times higher
than where it began the day and Masa
made more than 150 million dollars but
he was just getting started he followed
up his Yahoo windfall with a dizzying
spree of Investments he barely paused to
separate the trash from the treasure he
was just moving too fast it's believed
that between 1996 and 2000 SoftBank
invested in around 250 internet startups
an average of about one per week 10 or
20 times as many as the average VC fund
Masa was everywhere he raised a new fund
focused exclusively on late stage
companies the precursor to what is today
called growth investing he launched
Japanese subsidiaries of SoftBank
portfolio companies like Yahoo and
E-Trade he raised funds in South Korea
Japan and Hong Kong he partnered with
Rupert Murdoch to invest in Australia
and New Zealand and India opened Venture
offices is in Mexico Brazil and
Argentina it's estimated that masa's son
increased his personal wealth by about
15 billion dollars in the second half of
the 90s Masa didn't care about Alpha the
premium and investor earns from the
appreciation of an individual asset he
was all in on beta the yield from just
being in the market and so long as the
tide was Rising it was lifting all the
boats he combined one Central Insight
the surging popularity of the internet
and the wave of startups it created with
massive scale and a ruthless
determination to get what he wanted he
wasn't deterred by paying extremely high
prices other VC funds did more due
diligence they deployed Capital more
carefully but they didn't make as much
money as Masa and he was about to make a
lot more in January of 2000 a
little-known Chinese entrepreneur was
desperate for more Capital his name was
Jack Ma and his company was called
Alibaba his bank Goldman Sachs was
hesitant about investing more the bosses
instructed Shirley Lin the leader of
their asia-focused private Equity arm to
try and find Outside investment for
Alibaba and a bunch of other Chinese
startups Lin spoke to her colleague Mark
Schwartz the chairman of Goldman's Asia
Pacific Division
he was also on the board of SoftBank
which company is most desperate he asked
Lynn Alibaba she answered right away
Alibaba is very very desperate it wasn't
long before Masa was in Beijing meeting
with local Tech entrepreneurs Masa took
an immediate liking to Jack ma he said
he saw a glint in his eyes the two shook
hands on an investment and Masa
whispered some advice spend the money
fast and expand rapidly deals need more
than handshakes so the pair met again
this time in masa's Tokyo office Shirley
Lin the biggest incumbent shareholder
was there too she suggested that
SoftBank invest 20 million dollars for a
20 stake valuing Alibaba at 100 million
dollars ten times what she and her
co-investors had paid three months
earlier she might have thought this was
just an opening Gambit the first step in
a delicate dance of haggling over a deal
not for Masa he said yes right away in
fact he ended up taking a 34 stake why
did he just get Good Vibes that's part
of it but that's not the whole picture
you know by now that Masa paid attention
to his intuitions but his huge Holdings
and many board positions gave him a
massive Advantage access to information
Masa was on the board of the tech
conglomerate Cisco through that he knew
that router sails to China were taking
off that could mean only one thing
personal internet use was about to
explode so he should seize every
opportunity to invest in companies that
would benefit the most when Masa shook
hands with Jack ma he ensured that
softbank's valuation would Peak at more
than 200 billion dollars and at the same
time without him even knowing it he had
saved SoftBank because the bubble that
took SoftBank to the top of the world
was about to burst the.com crash wiped
out tons of startups that wanted to
exploit the new popularity of the
internet and because of low interest
rates had easy access to Capital but
easy money doesn't create lasting value
concerned about an overheating economy
the Federal Reserve raised interest
rates the stock market nosedived and all
the companies that kept accepting
investor cash without spending the time
to develop a sustainable business model
failed the crash didn't just affect
startups that were never going to
succeed Cisco where Masa was a board
member lost more than 80 percent of its
value Amazon lost more than 90 percent
of its value how did SoftBank fare well
it lost about 99 of its market cap and
what about Masa he lost more than 70
billion dollars it's believed that no
person in history has ever lost more
than he did during the.com crash today
he wears it like a badge of Pride it's
almost like a boast but back then there
was no time to boast he had an Empire to
rebuild Alibaba was crucial to South
bank's recovery so was masa's decision
to restructure SoftBank into a telecoms
firm it established Yahoo Broadband in
2001 to harness the growing popularity
of home internet in 2004 it acquired
Japan Telecom in 2005 SoftBank actually
bought a Japanese professional baseball
team they're called the SoftBank Hawks
and SoftBank Stone owns them today in
2006 it bought Vodafone Japan and
rebranded it to SoftBank mobile Corp it
turns out that the year before the
release of the first iPhone was a smart
time to get into Mobile were these lucky
bets I don't think they were because
Masa was showing the world the same
thing over and over again he was buying
stakes in lots of companies but he was
actually placing bets on what he
believed the future would look like to
dive deeper into just what that means we
need to fast forward to June of 2010. to
softbank's 30th shareholder meeting and
a very interesting PowerPoint
presentation the 133 slide deck is about
masa's vision for the next 30 years of
SoftBank it shows some of the things he
wanted to focus on like solving
loneliness which he called the saddest
thing in people's lives it showed
softbank's performance over the first 30
years and some of his predictions for
the future such as his firm belief that
processing power would dramatically
exceed the power of the brain or that
our average life expectancy at least in
Japan would reach 2 100 or that we would
find all new ways to communicate with
each other according to Masa softbank's
commitment to the future is to achieve
the information revolution leading to
happiness for everyone it's easy to
laugh at this some of the slides are
pretty eccentric so why is this an
important part of this story because
when Masa expresses his beliefs about
the future you have to pay attention by
2010 he had a 30-year track record of
getting the most important predictions
right and even if they weren't right
they offered an insight into softbank's
investment strategy besides ideas like
artificial general intelligence and life
extension aren't that radical in the
Tech Community boss's slide deck
revealed his vision for the future that
Vision was about to come true literally
at the start of this video I said that
in 2017 masa's son convinced someone to
invest 45 billion dollars into the
SoftBank Vision Fund in just 45 minutes
so who was it it was the Crown Prince of
Saudi Arabia Muhammad bin Salman and how
did Masa convince him to put in so much
so fast you come to Tokyo for the first
time I want to give you a gift I want to
give you a Masa gift a Tokyo gift a
trillion dollar gift you invest 100
billion dollars into my fund and I give
you a trillion dollars even though he
actually got less than half of what he
asked for Masa still secured a massive
investment from Saudi Arabia's public
investment fund not bad for less than an
hour's work Masa sought out MBS because
he knew that the Crown Prince
technically the deputy Crown Prince at
the time wanted Saudi Arabia to be known
for something other than just oil and
because he knew that the vision fund
would give him that legitimacy the
vision fund was born a year earlier in
2016. Masa was on a flight to pitch
investors in the Middle East he wrote
down the number that he was targeting
for his new fund 30 billion dollars he
thought about it crossed it out and
replaced it with a bigger number a
hundred billion dollars Life's too short
to think small he told the deputy
sitting near him the vision fund is the
world's biggest bat on the future and
it's the culmination of masa's entire
career and philosophy Masa took the same
approach he had throughout his career
begin by understanding deep
technological Trends then invest as much
as possible to make that future a
reality of the 100 billion that made up
the vision fund almost half came from
Saudi Arabia the rest was provided by
The Sovereign wealth fund of the United
Arab Emirates Qualcomm apple and Foxconn
SoftBank put in 28 billion dollars about
12 percent of its assets the vision fund
was set up to make massive investments
in companies that bring about the
information revolution that Masa had
predicted back in 2010 the revolution
that would create happiness for everyone
the Common Thread that runs throughout
the vision fund's 450 portfolio
companies is that they are all in
industries that can be disrupted and
digitized that meant lots of investing
in smaller startups across emerging
Industries like AI Robotics and the
internet of things but also massive
investments in Tech enabled consumer and
workplace companies like uber we work by
dance and DD with enough left over for
investments in companies like wag Uber
but for dog walking and zoom a robot
powered Pizza Company Masa wasn't afraid
to back companies competing against each
other in the same markets this is
interesting for two reasons the first is
that Masa wasn't afraid to lose money in
the short term I guess losing more money
than anyone else in history makes you
pretty resilient but he knew he would
only be losing in the short term because
the vision fund leveraged a powerful
reality of modern tech winter takes all
competition enabled by Network effects
the companies with the best business
models that reached the most people and
designed the best user experience would
capture the biggest market share and use
those compounding advantages to become
monopolies the second is that just like
when Yahoo's Founders were presented
with an offer they couldn't refuse the
vision fund was simply too big to ignore
when it was raised it instantly became
the biggest VC fund ever five times
bigger than the Venture arms of
Blackstone and Goldman Sachs 20 20 times
bigger than Andreessen Horowitz when
Uber accepted eight billion dollars from
the vision Fund in 2018 their CEO said
rather than have their Capital Cannon
facing me I'd rather have their Capital
Cannon behind me these CEOs just had two
choices have SoftBank on their side or
against them the vision fund was
absolutely massive it invested in some
of the world's most recognizable
technology companies as well as hundreds
of promising startups an unusual
structure meant in captured most of the
upside tech company valuations were
growing massively so how did this all
happen let's look at 2019 the Visions
fund losses can be summed up by a core
investing principle your portfolio is
only as good as the companies in it what
happened in 2019 wework happened when
Masa son first met Adam Newman he gave
him three billion dollars he also told
Newman that while he appreciated how
crazy he was he needed to be crazier
Adam Newman took this advice a
combination of public reports about
company mismanagement and investor
doubts led to wework pulling its IPO
which had been planned for September as
early as January 2019 a massive series G
Rays had valued wework at 47 billion
dollars Masa tried to save wework but it
didn't work by the time wework went
public in October of 2021 it was valued
at just nine billion dollars other
failures like wirecard a German payments
processor that engaged in accounting
fraud made 2019 a miserable year for
Masa song Masa knew he had to change
things up he promised to push Vision
fund companies to actually generate
profits rather than constantly urging
them to be crazier faster and bigger but
it wasn't a change in philosophy that
made the vision fund scale to all new
heights it was a global pandemic you
remember the early days of covid-19
ordering food from your phone while
being stuck inside working from home
meme stocks it was a perfect storm of
events that rapidly accelerated the
digitization of society and with it the
growth of tech stocks covid turned
SoftBank into a giant ATM it paid down
its debts and paid out huge amounts to
investors in mid-2021 it posted an
annual net profit of 46 billion dollars
the biggest ever by a Japanese company
but then the macro environment changed
which dramatically revealed that Moss's
biggest strength the thing that helped
him become so successful and made him so
resilient when he lost 70 billion
dollars in the early 2000s was also his
biggest weakness Masa has always been an
optimist he wouldn't have had the same
success if he wasn't but that optimism
created big blind spots investing in 10
times as many companies as other VC
funds came at the cost of due diligence
which meant Masa was slow to notice
problems at portfolio companies like
wework wire card and green cell and too
hasty to launch ill-advised Ventures
like the North Star Trading unit
investing almost exclusively in startups
that never turned a profit in the belief
that enough of them would become huge
monopolies meant SoftBank has always
struggled to achieve significant cash
flow and made it extremely vulnerable
High inflation which has crashed tech
stocks across the world other events
like the Chinese government Crackdown on
its tech companies which destroyed most
of the value in important SoftBank
portfolio companies like Alibaba and
Didi were mostly down to bad luck but
even bad luck can be hedged with the
right strategy the performance of The
Vision fund and SoftBank as a whole is
fundamentally tied to the prospects of
the tech sector that's great when you're
in one of the biggest bull markets ever
but Bulls can become Bears very quickly
in May of 2022 SoftBank revealed that
its two Vision funds lost 27 billion
dollars last fiscal year sometimes
radical optimism has a high price tag
but Masa is Keeping the Faith when asked
about softbank's recent troubles he
simply said when it rains you open an
umbrella Masa sown grew up in an
illegally built Shack and became a
millionaire in a foreign country before
the age of 20. he went back home and
built a business from nothing into one
worth billions then he revolutionized
the BC industry by making the big
Investments ever seen yet today he's
remembered more for his failures than
his successes SoftBank is hard to
understand and easy to criticize many of
those criticisms including about its
structure and its governance are fair
but beyond all the noise SoftBank
embodies masa's most defining character
trait one that has stayed with him from
the illegal Shack in tonsu to Berkeley
all the way to the present the belief
that tomorrow will be better than today
and that with enough effort you can
create the future you want